get tools soon in other words Fabian
also talked about an important lesson
get tools in place early you can work 12
hours a day but there's marketing
automation tools for social media to
automate your cheats there are um there
is accounting tools that are out there
there's CRM like odoo he said don't wait
to get the tools in place if you're
automating systems now you can actually
make money go further early on you have
to select the systems that are not
overly expensive sometimes will help you
turn one person who's doing your
accounting into one and a half people
because you have tools to help you so
get the tools in place early I thought
was also a really really great learning